sziasztok a következő témám számomra egy
hihetetlenül érdekes téma lesz a gépi
tanulás a mesterséges intelligencia a
nagynyelvi modelleknek a világát fogjuk
egy kicsit körbejárni valójában mitől
lett ennyire népszerű ez a téma hogyan
alakítja át a világunkat milyen hozadéka
lesz ennek a a hihetetlen hullámnak ami
ami folyamatosan alakít mindent a
következő vendégem szabó péter aki
nagynyelvi modelleket gép tanulásokat
kutató szakember valamint több üzlet
bizisnek a tulajdonosa hietetlenül
izgalmas témákat jártunk körbe úyhogy
tartsatok velünk és ne felejtsetek el
feliratkozni